the best negotiators on earth women you
don't even know they're [ __ ] making
you do something
damn bruh what is that it's a rose
yeah yeah i know you're in a
relationship
input on [ __ ] that they had no business
having input on why'd you get something
pretty like a flower oh singapore
getting like a grim reaper no babe i'm
sick of these [ __ ] death tattoos
get something cute on your arm
and here you are you got a [ __ ] wrote
y'all better get married now otherwise
every girl in the future gonna be like
look at this gay [ __ ] gotta roll
on his bicycle thank you i thought he
was cute till i saw how gay he was now i
gotta go have sex with somebody else cuz
he's [ __ ] dudes for the rest of his
life
got a [ __ ] rosa you might as well
have a rainbow flag on your forehead
don't lie and say it was his idea no way
that was his idea dudes don't like roses
ever
oh yeah you buy him roses for his
[ __ ] birthday
you just he give it oh my god
dog i walk by flowers all the time and
my wife is like let's take a picture i'm
like [ __ ]
we're in [ __ ] des moines why we need
pictures of flowers
take her to an arboretum she could lose
her [ __ ] mind i can't take her to the
botanical gardens because she's gonna
there's tulips everywhere
damn who gives a [ __ ] dog they're
flowers
they don't bear no fruit you don't get
no [ __ ] food off of rose this [ __ ]
just make you sneeze and march that's
all it does
and now you got one for the rest of your
life that you gotta [ __ ] look at
every time you shampoo your hair you're
like god damn it this [ __ ]
okay can you
that is uh
yeah what is that that's a skull it's a
[ __ ] skull inside of what a gear
shift that's the manliest tattoo you
could possibly get and you think this is
his idea you think he went from [ __ ]
skull and gear shift to giant rose
just admit he's a hostage in this
relationship just be honest with
yourself and i'm not talking to you i'm
talking all [ __ ] significant others
that are female stop pretending we got
freedom you think i wanna wear jewelry
for the rest of my life no
i'm gonna be honest
this [ __ ] is a beautiful rose
[Laughter]
[Music]
i just don't like what it represents
why did she tell you you need it what is
that supposed to represent what are you
gonna lie to us and be like no this is
why i wanted a rose well her middle name
is rose oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah what a huh
[Laughter]
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]